John Hanks was a dude born in the 1690s
we have no idea what he looked like but
his great great grandson was Abraham
Lincoln and his great great great great
great great grandson is Tom Hanks I
smell
[Music]
cousins but what kind of cousin are they
well here's how cousin terminology works
if you have two individuals and you know
their last shared ancestor take the one
who's closest and count how many
generations are in between one 2 three
now take the individuals and find out
how many generations separate them okay
1 2 3 4 so Tom Hanks and Abraham Lincoln
are third cousins four times removed my
cousin's kid is my first cousin once
removed but my kid and my cousin's kid
well they are one two second cousins
with no removal if you want a full
breakdown of family and cousin
nomenclature check out my video on the
ding Channel